[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OKAY.
IT'S TIME TO GET REAL ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL.
"LET'S KEEP IT 100".
I LIKE THAT. NORMALLY IN THIS
SEGMENT
I ASK EACH PERSON A QUESTION
AND ASK THEM
TO KEEP IT 100 BECAUSE THIS IS
THE BLACK DAD SUMMIT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE OUR VERY FIRST SPEED
ROUND, SO YOU ALL GET TO
ANSWER THE SAME QUESTION.
WE WILL HAVE A COUPLE OF THESE.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IT A
100 PERCENT REAL. IF YOU DON'T,
THE AUDIENCE WILL--
[BOOING]
IF THEY LIKE IT THEY WILL CLAP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LET'S START, LET'S START WITH
YOU, COMMON.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHARLES WANTS TO GO LAST.
IN THE SUPER BOWL, RICHARD
SHERMAN, HE HAS A GIRLFRIEND.
SHE WAS GONNA HAVE A BABY
RIGHT.
THERE WAS A CHANT THAT SHE MIGHT
OF GONE INTO LABOR.
SAY YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY IN
THE SUPER BOWL OR BE THERE FOR
THE BIRTH OF YOUR BABY.
OKAY.
ONE OR THE OTHER.
WHICH ONE DO YOU DO?
>> IS IT MY FIRST CHILD?
[LAUGHING]
>> YES.
YES.
>> ALRIGHT.
[LAUGHING]
>> SUPER BOWL.
>> I THINK YOU GOT A 100 THERE.
I LIKE THAT.
JOE, SUPER BOWL.
>> MY FIRST CHILD I'M THERE,
MAN.
>> YOU GOING TO BE THERE FOR THE
BABY.
>> THE BABY.
>> WHAT IF YOU'RE THE
QUARTERBACK.
>> THE SUB HAS TO COME IN MAN.
FAMILY FIRST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I BELIEVE HIM.
MIKE.
>> I'M WITH JOE ON THAT ONE.
I'M GOING --
>> DON'T TRY TO LIE TO ME.
YOU'RE GOING TO THE SUPER BOWL.
>> I'M GOING TO WATCH MY KID BE
BORN.
>> ALRIGHT.
>> CHARLES?
SUPER BOWL OR SEE THE BIRTH OF
YOUR BABY.
>> BIRTH OF THE BABY.
>> HAPPY WIFE, HAPPY LIFE.
[LAUGHING]
>> ALRIGHT.
>> HAPPY WIFE, HAPPY LIFE.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW -- I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY.
>> I WANT TO KNOW.
>> I THINK I MIGHT GO TO THE
SUPER BOWL.
[LAUGHING]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HEY, I CAN HAVE MORE KIDS.
I MAY NEVER GET ANOTHER CHANCE
TO GO TO THE SUPER BOWL.
SEND ME YOUR TWEETS.
[BEEP]
>> ALRIGHT.
WE BROUGHT UP THE QUESTION OF
MARRIAGE.
HOW A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST ARE NOT
MARRYING ANYMORE.
NOW, JOE, I WILL START WITH YOU
ON THIS ONE.
IS IT BECAUSE BLACK WOMEN ARE
TOO BOSSY?
ARE BLACK WOMEN TOO BOSSY.
>> I HAVE TO THE GO TO THE
BATHROOM.
I WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> KEEP IT ONE HUNDRED.
>> BLACK WOMEN HAVE OPINIONS
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU DIDN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
OKAY.
MIKE.
YOU FROM THE ISLANDS.
>> I LOVE BLACK WOMEN.
>> ARE BLACK WOMEN --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> ARE THEY TOO BOSSY?
>> I'M NOT GETTING INVOLVED IN
THAT.
I'M NOT GETTING INVOLVED IN
>> OKAY.
CHARLES, CHARLES, ON A SCALE OF
1-10 HOW BOSSY ARE BLACK WOMEN.
GIVE ME A NUMBER.
GIVE ME A NUMBER?
YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF THIS.
NO, NO, NO.
SCALE 1-10.
WE'RE CHANGING IT UP NOW.
SCALE 1-0.
[LAUGHING]
KEEP IT 100.
GIVE ME A NUMBER.
>> IT BETTER NOT BE UNDER FIVE.
>> WHAT -- WHAT?
[LAUGHING]
>> SCALE 1-10.
>> I'M NOT DOING THAT.
>> LAST ONE.
COMMON IS FEARLESS, RIGHT.
COMMON, WHICH BLACK WOMEN ARE
THE BOSSIEST.
PROFESSIONAL BLACK ATHLETE
WOMEN.
PROFESSIONAL SINGING BLACK
OR PROFESSIONAL ACTRESS BLACK
WOMEN.
AND WE KNOW WHO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
KEEP IT A HUNDRED PERCENT.
WHICH ONE, WHICH ONE?
>> WE'RE GOING WITH PROFESSIONAL
SINGING BLACK WOMEN.
>> THAT'S KEEPING IT A HUNDRED.
HE WILL NEED ALL OF YOU.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.